I love the movie my whole family we sat
down and watch it is so great you are so
great but one question did that hurt
your voice because you are like the
whole time hi Kelly we met once before I
know but you don't understand that good
like I needed it like last week because
it's just so much work in our kids and I
got it I was like what is this and
somebody kind of was talking about it
and then my shows that are you gonna
interview Josh's and as to I started
looking at it and I watched every second
of twice I watched it I loved that y'all
redid the lines and the best ones I love
that everybody got on like was that so
cool
Josh Josh is I mean these kind of
situations when there's drama and
there's you know pain and whatever
there's always an opportunity or
something good to happen and Josh just
because he's a true fan and because he
is who he is he like brought the band
back together like legit and younger
than my brother and my sisters so I
watched all that's all I didn't have a
choice to what I didn't get to choose so
I still watch this and they were oh my
god I love you all so much you'd have no
idea I was so - how much you just want
to hug this girl right now so Chris
coronavirus right now for a group hug
you have no idea go though no I was just
gonna say looking at the three of us I'm
pretty sure
it's like two brothers and a sister I'm
pretty sure that we're I will be your
family subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going